Good morning and welcome to talks at Google in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Today it is my great pleasure to introduce Dr Anna Free Bowl of Massachusetts
Institute of Technology where she is assistant professor in the Department of
Physics.
She's here today to discuss her book searching for the oldest stars,
ancient relics from the early universe.
Why do we care?
Because if it's not lithium hydrogen or helium,
it came from the stars.
Dr Feeble herself along with colleagues is responsible for discovering many of
these stars.
And in her book she discovers the process by which he does it.
The book itself is um,
one of the rare books in which we get a dose of actual science in terms of both
experts and lay people can understand that as well as a great behind the scenes
look at what's involved in marathon observatory sessions to discover the stars
and map them.
So without further ado,
please join me in welcoming Dr Ama free bump.
Thank you so much for their grades.
And I'm introduction.
I'm very excited to be here and to talk about my book.
It's been a in the making for quite a while.
So it's really,
I'm really pleased that it's finally out and it really got very exciting.
Um,
so I wanted to quickly introduce and tell you a little bit what my goal was of
all these years.
I'm very,
of course I'm a scientist.
I'm very interested on conveying my research results,
but also the scientific method to the,
to the wider audience.
And a,
in this case,
I,
I have to quote my mom because I regularly tell her,
oh,
I'm going to the telescope I'm going observing.
And she always has like,
yeah,
yeah.
But,
um,
now after even having written the book,
and of course her reading it in great detail,
she really understands what this means.
And the point of this is that the public really doesn't know what scientists do
all day long.
And this thing of going,
observing and using telescopes is certainly very mysterious to anyone who hasn't
been at the telescope.
And they're even lots of astronomers who haven't been at a big telescope.
So this is really a widespread issue.
And so I wanted to write a book that is not your typical popular science book
that presents just the scientific results,
but it also wanted to,
um,
tell the story of how we get there.
As it turns out,
it's never really a straight line.
And so the many wine,
oh,
the big windy road is,
um,
is characterized by,
good luck and bad luck and many other interesting things.
And so I have devoted several chapters,
two to that journey.
And so yeah,
my motto is the journey is the destination because I became a scientist because
I wanted to find things out and not necessarily do have the flashiest off
results.
Obviously that's really great when that happens and it's a part of the journey,
the destination.
But I'm really,
what I do on a daily basis is,
is not,
um,
not all that flashy,
but it's nevertheless really interesting.
And so I want to give and realistic insight into what,
what astronomers to on a daily basis.
So,
but let's get the story started.
Let's start right at the beginning,
some 14 billion years ago.
So the big bang occurred some 14 billion years ago.
And the universe at that time consisted of just three elements,
hydrogen,
helium and lithium.
And,
uh,
from that primordial gas,
the very first stars emerged and they were made from hydrogen,
helium,
and lithium and nothing else.
Now,
these stars had very short lives because they have a very high mass.
Uh,
I'll touch on that a little bit later again.
so they were short lived and when they exploded as gigantic supernovae the
elements that they had been cooking,
I'd the additional elements that they had been cooking up in their course to
sustain their luminosity,
to shine even for their short lives there were expelled into the interstellar
medium,
into the universe.
And that changed everything because now the universe consisted not just of
hydrogen,
helium and lithium,
but also have elements like carbon and oxygen and iron.
And that has a whole lot of ramifications for additional star formation and
author for galaxy formation.
So clearly these stars,
uh,
our shirt in a new era in the universe and then start and galaxy formation
indeed had a chance to take off.
So we have the slightly enriched material here and from that the next
generations of stars formed and is actually those early generations here.
The second one in particular that we are trying to find because these stars here
now or some of these stars in that generation included low mass stars.
It's law,
small little stores and they have a very long lifetime.
So they are still around today.
And those are the guys said,
we are hunting down without big telescopes.
So I want to tell you more about how we do that and what we learned from finding
these stars.
But first let's talk a little bit about chemical evolution.
That is the,
the buildup,
the,
the success of buildup of heavy elements heavier than hydrogen,
helium and lithium in the universe of a billions of years.
Imagine that this here is the primordial gas cloud.
So just what was there after the Big Bang and the very first stars forms and
they're evolved and uh,
they exploded a supernovae and saw the elements that they cooked up inside their
cores for energy production.
They got ejected back into the reservoir here.
Then this is enriched a little bit,
you'll form the next generation of stars and then it goes round and round and
round.
And um,
there are several consequences.
Um,
you can immediately see that if you have this cycle here,
got run only a few times as opposed to a few hundred or a thousand times,
that the amount of the heavy elements in the resulting stars will increase.
So all their stores contain much fewer of the elements and the younger ones
contain more.
And the sun for a reference also formed at some point,
probably when the cycle had gone round,
maybe a thousand times in that locale in this local region where the sun formed
later.
So,
um,
and the sun contains,
I'll,
I'll have another slide on that contains a whole 1.4% of the heavy elements.
So that's already a lot.
But,
um,
I'll say a little bit more about this in a second.
So our prime primary goal is when we searched for the oldest stars is to look
for the stats with the least amount of heavy elements in them.
Because as it turns out,
it's incredibly difficult to actually obtain an actual age for the star.
However,
at the very end,
I'll show you one example of where we manage to do that.
So that tests kind of wraps it all up.
Nice.
Uh,
so we have to talk about Stella chemical compositions.
And for reference here I have at the top,
um,
the composition of the universe.
I'm after the Big Bang and already mentioned this,
but you have hydrogen,
75% helium,
25%,
and just a tiny sprinkle of lithium.
So I excluded that because actually it's not too relevant for the remainder of
my talk.
And then,
um,
after about 9 billion years of chemical evolution,
the sun formed,
um,
that was about 4.6 billion years ago.
And you can see how the composition changed.
Hydrogen God converted into helium and helium got converted into heavier
elements.
So the sun is very rich in heavier elements,
comparatively,
a whole one point percent.
And so what we are doing is we are looking for stars that have million times
less than this.
Okay,
so a whole different ballgame.
But that gives you an idea of what the,
the range as we are we are playing with.
Yeah.
So there are lots of chemical elements in the periodic table here.
A few illustrated,
I hope you're a little coffee shop over there.
We'll soon sale element cupcakes.
I'm sure they will taste particularly sweet.
There will certainly would to me.
Um,
a few are highlighted here.
M C N O P s o n n.
O,
sorry,
c,
n o p.S that are the elements of life.
W W US humans.
We come,
we consists mostly of carbon.
All life forms are carbon based and uh,
all of these in particular of these five elements here,
but we contain also a whole bunch of other elements.
Um,
and uh,
all that material of course needs to come from somewhere.
And I already mentioned that stars produce elements for energy production.
But,
uh,
one thing that is often forgotten is that we actually also carry a little big
bang material in us because our bodies consist 90% of water and water is made of
hydrogen and oxygen and those protons in the hydrogen there were certainly
recycled through stars,
but they were made in the big bang.
And so we're not just children of the stars were also children of the big bang.
And so I think that's really nice that we can feel a little connected to,
to ride the beginning.
And so I,
uh,
already mentioned he had just a few pretty pictures because in every astronomy
talk you also need a few pretty fractures.
This is the star forming region here.
Um,
but,
uh,
the elements are not just made in stars.
They're also made in Supernova explosions.
Here are a few examples of areas,
uh,
so called Super Nova remnants and uh,
so that,
that adjust the,
um,
the shells of heavy element material that are still expanding since the
explosion.
And you can actually see in the different colors here,
they are depicting different elements.
So you can literally witness how these new elements that have produced and stars
and Supernova explosions are being dispersed in to,
uh,
the costs.
Moss
here is another version of the periodic table.
You can see that,
uh,
I'm ready for lunch because I like her somewhat,
unusual depictions of the periodic table of the elements.
But then I'm also not a chemist,
I'm astronomer.
So we take a unique spin on the periodic table because you probably know from
your chemistry classes that in chemistry here and according to the colors,
the rows,
the columns,
sorry,
the columns are very important in chemistry because the elements in a column
have similar properties.
As an astronomer,
I couldn't care less about the columns,
okay.
About the rose because the elements are the subsequently made.
Um,
if you want to create iron here,
you have to create these guys here beforehand.
So it goes one,
two,
one,
two to get where you have to go.
So we care for the rose.
And so maybe I have to assume vague,
one of those hundred and nine cupcakes,
color them in a slightly different way.
But,
uh,
let's get to the,
to the hard off the matters.
So my work is often called Stella archaeology because we take these survivor
staffs that are in the Milky Way today and we study their chemical composition
so that we can for their age or at least their formation era due to the small
amounts of heavy elements in them.
And,
uh,
from that we can then infer what the composition of this gas cloud was this
little guy's farm from.
And that tells us,
um,
what exactly came out of one of those first star Supernova explosions.
Because as I said in the beginning,
these guys here are very massive and short lift so we can actually not study
them anymore.
The only way we can do this is through this indirect way of looking at their
Stella genes that are incorporated into the next generation of stars.
So obviously that requires that we have to find these second generation stars
here.
But,
um,
we,
we are finding them now and so we can infer a properties off.
He's very first stores that really shaped the universe at this early time.
Okay.
So where do we find these,
these doors?
Let's look at the milky way for a second.
Heroes,
a top view.
And we are in a,
we live in a spiral galaxy.
This is the galactic center.
It's very brightly lit.
You can actually see it here.
This is what we see on the sky because we sit over here about two thirds on the
way out.
And in the,
uh,
in the northern hemisphere.
From here,
we actually looking out.
So we,
what we see on the sky is this spiral arm here.
We asked if we,
if we go to the Southern Hemisphere,
um,
we look in that direction and we see that spiral arm here,
but it's back lit by the Galactic Center.
And that's where the Mickey with Oh much banner in the south.
Uh,
and this is a picture of the south,
so you can see the,
um,
the,
the back lighting off the Galactic Center here.
Um,
and um,
he or is,
it is a further edge on view.
Um,
what I want to focus on now is,
is actually not the disc itself at all.
This outer region here that we call the halo two was very thinly populated
spherical envelope that kind of protects the swirls around the desk.
And uh,
we have um,
lots of,
lots of things living in their little old halo stars and those are the ones we
want to find a spread.
It's a little bit like the junk yard of the gout Alexi actually.
Uh,
and uh,
we also have little dwarf galaxies that are orbiting the Milky Way as well.
And we study those as well.
So,
um,
I told you a little bit about stars now and that they are old.
You can probably guess that they're not very rare because a lot of stores have
formed since then.
So I want to put this to a test with you.
Well,
can tell me which one's the oldest one
here.
I give you a hint.
It's not this guy here in the middle that that would be too easy.
That can only be wrong answers here.
Actually there will likely be wrong,
but why don't you give it a try?
Yes.
The reddest one.
Why do we have red one?
We have a red one here.
This one,
perhaps this one here.
Okay,
well it's not the red.
This one.
Maybe the bluest warm.
Well Fun.
That's a,
that's a good deduction.
Yeah.
Um,
however,
if you put a star further away,
it'll appear smaller.
So from this collective image here,
we,
we can't really tell.
Well,
I can tell you one thing.
I have absolutely no clue.
Uh,
which SARS off and restores yard.
All we can see in this image that all that have you have seen is that there are
different EP parents sizes and different colors.
Because a picture like that is really not giving you any more information.
Now that's a really good information,
but it's limited information.
What do we need to do?
Well,
we need to use a different technique that's called spectroscopy.
It doesn't deliver pretty pictures,
but oh boy,
it delivers information and you guys hopefully appreciate that.
So,
um,
we use the method of spectroscopy to explore the,
the outer atmosphere of the star and a weekend would that be,
can bridge very large distances.
And it's almost like we're taking a little piece of the store.
And,
um,
uh,
looking at it in the lab,
kind of like the CSI guys guys.
And they are mass spectrometers.
We use big telescopes for that.
But before I tell you a little bit more about that,
I just wanted to make one more point named he's a picture's worth a thousand
words.
A bout a spectrum is worth a thousand pictures because this is a star and this
is a picture of a very important star.
Okay.
But when you look at the picture,
it's a fuzzy blob in the universe.
How boring.
That's incredibly boring.
It doesn't really tell us anything.
But the spectroscopic analysis has revealed that this is the by the,
by now,
second most iron our star.
So this is a second generation star in the universe.
That's pretty neat,
I think.
So let's briefly recap,
uh,
what,
what we do in terms of,
uh,
a chemical abundance analysis that is based on a spectrum.
We,
um,
collect the starlight with a big telescope and we have a spectrograph which just
basically a prison,
uh,
in,
here I saw the prison,
um,
splits up the light into the rainbow colors and then you get a spectrum like
that.
It doesn't look quite like the rainbow because there are all these dark lines in
here.
And each dark line we first to,
um,
a little piece of light that is lost.
And what's happening in the Stella surface that we're observing,
there are all sorts of elements,
atoms swirling around and each element absorbs at certain wavelength.
And,
um,
while absorption means the light is absorbed,
it's gone.
And so that's where we see these lines here on actually the across cross cut
through here is shown up here and you can see indeed all these lines here.
These are all absorption lines.
And if we take a little peek,
a little look,
a closer look here,
we have hydrogen lines here and here's even a tiny calcium line so we can
measure the strength of these lines and then infer their abundance because
that's really what we want in order to determine,
okay,
how much of these heavy elements is there and is that a star that could have
formed as part of the second generation because it's abundance are so low.
And so I already hinted that bad.
These stars are very rare.
There are forums 13 billion years ago and since then the universe has been quite
busy making SARS.
And so we need big sky surveys to go from hundreds,
sorry,
from millions,
actually hundreds of millions,
almost stars,
200 actual hundreds and then dozens.
And we do that by getting different kinds of spectrum and the quality goes up
and up.
We really need very high resolution spectrum here,
which just means we really stretched the light out,
uh,
to an extreme to get to really,
really fine spectral details here.
So we can measure this tiny little iron line here.
And here's another one.
This is the calcium line here,
uh,
to do our work.
So it's a,
it's quite painstaking and it takes years sometimes to go from here to here,
but,
um,
it's,
it's really awesome when we get there.
Okay.
And so let me tell you a little bit about the observing,
uh,
because it's absolutely fascinating to to go there and to take your data and
have these discovery moments.
And so that was really a big,
um,
uh,
something that I really wanted to share with everyone.
And so here are just a few pictures of big telescopes so that I have used,
uh,
I will tell you a little bit more about the Magellan telescopes here.
Are these,
how the Keck telescopes on her way.
Maybe you have been to Hawaii.
You can even go up the summit,
almost up to the summit and,
um,
take a telescope tour if you're ever there.
Uh,
the,
the Japanese telescopes also up on,
on one Ikea and then also in Chile,
uh,
some of the European telescopes.
So lots out there.
And,
uh,
here are the Magellan telescopes.
I take students there.
Uh,
oh,
uh,
this was an Undergrad at MIT.
So I like to train students also from early on and I have one,
some extra funds to take specifically undergrads to the telescope to give them
the research experience very early on.
It's very inspiring to them.
And um,
so far they've all gone into science or stuck with a science and it's been
always very exciting.
So I really love going there even when it's cloudy like this,
but at least to make some pretty pictures and uh,
that's how it looks at night.
This isn't even the,
the center part of the Milky Way.
Just,
um,
just,
the spiral arm party or the nonvascular part,
the galactic center sort of down here.
Um,
I was observing some dwarf galaxy stores with that telescope while I had to
stand very still for 30 seconds.
So,
um,
that,
that was exciting.
But we show you some movies really give you the visual counterpart to what I
described in the book.
So these are the two telescopes and this is set up mine,
the one I always use.
And you can see the make you way now moving up,
right?
And you can clearly see the back backlit,
um,
spiral arm here.
This is the galactic center and it's just absolutely majestic.
And actually if the moon is down and you have the Milky Way above you,
you can see your own shadow in the light of the stars,
right?
Just think about that for a sec.
That's just truly magical
by the moon does come up once in awhile.
And Rex,
you're,
uh,
you're a time labs.
But
as I said,
this is about realistic experiences and not,
um,
fudge things.
Like it's always dark and the Milky Way is always up.
So I just wanted to just show how,
how it really is the good,
bad,
and the ugly.
Okay.
And I have another one because this one was the,
um,
okay.
The outside,
but what happens inside
lots of keyboards,
Dalton buttons
and lots of spectrum.
And you'll see here the round spectrum and not yet fully processed,
but you see the absorption lines in them.
So I inspect the strength of both absorption life immediately after every
observation and on Yay or nay.
So either I go onto the next target or like,
oh,
maybe I need take more care here.
And uh,
yeah,
that happens all night long.
That's what astronomers are doing,
owner law.
Um,
but as I said was good luck and there's bad luck.
I have been at the telescope many times and it was completely cloudy and I came
home empty handed.
I have to wait for a year until I get time again that I actually have to
competitively win first.
So sometimes the universe is just against you,
all the weather gods,
but again it makes for a pretty pictures.
You can see here,
this is,
I'm Scorpion on Torres.
Okay.
So even through the clouds you can actually see quite a lot of stars and 10 thus
depends how thick the clouds or whether you keep observing through the clouds or
you have to stop because there's just nothing coming through anymore
like in this case.
But at least it works out pretty artsy.
What you see here is a,
well the trucks on the highway light pollution is a big issue.
Even at the telescopes.
Every year I go there,
it gets a little bit worse.
The CDs get a little bit bigger or they a little more trucks on the road.
It's,
it's no good.
It's really affecting us.
And this is in the Atacama desert in 2,500 meters up in the mountains.
My Bud,
we can see very far because the era so good
and then it gets light again in the morning.
So,
um,
if you like these kinds of clips or would like to show them to someone else who
might be interested in seeing what astronomers are doing,
epic telescopes,
um,
you can put my name into Youtube,
I guess.
You know how that works.
Um,
you can also tweet me or just check out my website.
So I have a whole bunch of things they are,
because my outreach program was called science.
It's a human thing,
right?
We,
it's people who are doing this.
So we should show people doing it pretty simple yet apparently so difficult
back to the science.
So,
or here is this picture again,
this fuzzy blob.
This is,
uh,
one of the most important Cyrus we have found.
It's,
uh,
as far as we know is a second generation star because it's iron abundance and
other elements are so deficient that only one first star Supernova is required
or needed,
um,
to produce all these elements that we see in the star.
Now I should say here for clarification,
this star is,
um,
actually really unevolved.
It has not even started yet.
I'm converting anything else but hydrogen to helium in its core.
So this star has not really made any heavy elements itself.
Whatever we find in the Stella surface today came from the birth gas cloud from
which the star form,
which means that must have come from that previous generation star that enriched
that gas.
Okay.
So this is really the pinnacle,
uh,
of,
of our work and um,
how much iron is in there?
Well,
stars obviously little bit bigger than the earth,
about 300,000 times.
Um,
but if you want to make the comparison,
you take the earth iron core and it's about 1% of the earth I core that has
spread throughout my little star there.
So that supernova produced about that match,
which actually should you,
uh,
which,
which makes you think like could the earth have formed early on in the universe?
Well,
the answer is clearly no because you needed at least 100 supernovae to produce
as much iron in the universe to even make up the earth iron core.
Correct.
So it took probably several billion years before there was enough material out
there to,
to have planets form,
um,
that,
that sort of transition of when the first planets emerged as,
as currently researched.
And a certainly very,
very exciting topic.
And,
um,
yeah,
I look forward to knowing the answer,
but a no planets in the early universe.
And so what,
what do we learn from this?
Now?
I already mentioned many tidbits,
so let's put this together.
So we,
we usually use iron,
but also elements like carbon and oxygen to try to,
um,
to figure out what,
what went on in the Supernova.
And we work with people who calculate how many elements,
uh,
produced by the star itself as it is,
as a does before it explodes.
Um,
and then in the supernova explosion and we compare those models and then we
figure out,
oh,
you know,
it was this and this much that came out of this for a star.
And this really is the,
the one and owned the diagnostic
tool that we have to study the properties of the first stores.
So what are we interested in?
Well,
first of all be interested in their masters because theory has actually told us
that he's first stars were very massive.
It's actually very difficult for stars to form from just hydrogen,
helium and lithium.
It can't really cool down.
So I can't really clump well.
And so it's difficult to make small stout.
So we would like to confirm that the Theorosa rate,
um,
and that they have,
high master's maybe I saw theory says maybe up to a hundred solar masses a
hundred times the mass of the sun.
And indeed our works from this comparison.
We have found that,
uh,
the first stars might have been something like 50 or 60 saw land masses.
No,
it's not exactly a hundred,
but that was just a ballpark number to start with.
So it's definitely more than 10 or 15,
which is the typical math for two days,
larger stores,
you know,
so kind of different back then.
But we can also learn about,
uh,
the explosion mechanism and the explosion of energy and a,
that is very important for understanding really with how much power these stars
started to,
to change the universe when they exploded.
There are all sorts of homey keep ramifications that come from there depending
on how violently these stars exploded.
So we have a whole bunch of ongoing sky's service that help us,
uh,
to find more of these stores,
especially some that have a very,
uh,
that involve in new technique that is a lot more efficient now.
So,
um,
hopefully we'll find a lot more of these guys soon.
I think,
uh,
in the last few minutes I'd like to introduce this second star to you,
um,
here,
uh,
another fuzzy blob in the universe.
Now this one is actually fairly bright.
So if you have a small telescope at home or you know,
someone who has,
you can actually take a picture of yourself.
Um,
this was done by taken by an amateur astronomer and d send me those picture
there.
So that's Kinda Nice.
But again,
you need that spectroscopic knowledge to say that this is one of the oldest
stars.
So we know because we have measured each.
And so what's the big deal here?
We have taken a spectrum and the spectrum was very unusual because it contained
absorption lines from very heavy rare earths earth elements and uh,
and that included elements,
uh,
like ethereum and uranium.
And you hopefully know that these are radioactive elements.
So as soon as you deal with radioactive material,
uh,
you have yourself a clock.
So we're making use of that.
And um,
it basically works like the radio carbon method,
just we're dealing with slightly older fonts.
So,
uh,
if you think that this was the Supernova,
um,
these heavy elements,
including thorium uranium,
they got produced here,
they got expelled into the universe,
and then our little guy formed.
And all of this material got baked into the star.
And then,
um,
actually pretty much since the supernova explosion,
the radio active material,
I started to decay.
And today we measure what's laughed and we compare that with calculations for
how much was produced.
And Bang,
we have an age had all sounds really easy.
And the,
the concept is very straightforward.
Um,
before I show you why this is so hard,
let me just illustrate to you what it means to work on,
on some of those special stores.
So here are a few elements that we regularly measure in,
in all of our old stars.
Um,
we then have these purple ones here,
this other rare earth elements,
especially the ones here at the bottom,
uh,
that we can,
we can measure.
And there are,
these elements are produced only in Supernova explosions doing very,
they're a special conditions.
So the gold and the silver from your jewelry all comes from these very special
supernova explosions.
And this,
uh,
they are still a lot of open questions about this process that makes these
elements.
And so it's very exciting for us to find some of these sores.
And so we can chime into this question where and them,
it's like silver and gold actually come from and how exactly there are produced
in the universe.
So here is why this measurement takes an incredible amount of data and it's a
very difficult analysis because we want to measure the uranium abundances and
abundance.
And so here you have absorption lines,
magnesium,
iron neodymium,
Samarium I in here and do you see it's a blow up a system.
So if you look at this blue line,
this is a synthetic spectrum that we have created to model the star there
contains no uranium.
And the question is does dad one correspond to the observed data,
which is the dots included?
The answer is no.
Instead we have data that's a little bit lower,
which means there is a little uranium absorption.
And so we have then created model said kind of rubbed,
produced this here.
Um,
if the uranium was not decaying,
it would have been absorbed up to here.
So that would be easy to measure.
But it's good that it's the king because it gives us this clock.
So by making this measurement here requires x extremely,
um,
exquisite data,
but it worked because the stories are bright and we got an age,
well there's this nod,
precision cosmology.
But nevertheless,
it's an important contribution to,
um,
to the early universe or two studies of the early universe.
And it confirms that the whole story I have told you about the chemical
composition and that telling us that we,
uh,
that we can look back in time to this early era by measuring chemical abundances
is actually so here are different element ratios.
They all involve either [inaudible] or uranium or both.
And these are ages and in Berlin,
yes.
Now the universe is a 13.8 billion years.
So this is just a mathematical number that pops out.
Obviously it's unphysical,
but math doesn't really care about physics,
so we have to take it.
Uh,
but if you average all off this,
it comes out to about 13 billion years.
And that is a number of,
we like,
it's very consistent with the age of the universe.
Now,
there are some uncertainties of course,
but it is not 10 and it's not 5 billion years.
It's not like the sun and you know,
even 10 is still a while away from 14 here.
So the concept of stellar archaeology is correct if it works.
And,
uh,
these old stars here at first of all,
there really are old and we can use them to explore the early universe.
And of course before the era of these satellites that probe the cosmic Mac
Michael Microwave background radiation.
And that led to the very precise determination of the age of the universe to
13.8 billion years.
Methods like these where,
uh,
the standard to date the universe and to provide a lower limit to the age of the
universe.
So when I went to high school,
um,
uh,
that was still the standard and this would have made a great addition then.
Okay.
So that brings me to the end of it.
I hope I could give you just a tiny little bit,
uh,
often insight that these old staff's really,
I like little diamonds in the sky.
Um,
feel very rare.
they are difficult to come by,
but we have our methods.
I didn't have time to talk much about this,
but many contain actually unusually large amounts of carbon compared to their
other elements.
And that actually,
um,
indicates to us that carbon is not just an important element for us today since
we're all carbon based.
But it was probably also the most important element that that helped in the
early universe after the formation of the first stars.
So carbon really is the most important element if you ask me at all costs,
make times and um,
well the source are quite old.
So I would say they lost almost for until forever.
And,
uh,
we can address them very many different and exciting science questions with
them.
So there's almost an old staff or any kind of question you might have.
And of course when you find them,
they make you happy.
So I would just say,
and this my slides a little cut off there,
uh,
with our new,
an ongoing service and the big telescopes that we're using,
we are continuing this treasure hunt.
Thank you so much.
So,
um,
how many of these second generation stars are,
I know now,
uh,
so we,
I think we know about six,
five or six.
It depends a little bit on who you ask.
And it also depends a little bit on,
uh,
on the type office first SAR Supernova that you're modeling and how much it
outputs,
right?
So they are obviously a little variation,
but,
um,
we've come really a long while because in 2000 they were zero.
Right?
So,
okay,
that's 15 years ago.
But,
uh,
with our increasing the,
improving search techniques,
it's now kind of on the rise.
And,
and you mentioned that we've learned things about the first generation of stars.
Is there any prospect that someday we will have a telescope that will let us
actually see some of these first generation stars?
Well,
for that we would need to have a strong infrared telescope like the James Webb
space telescope that's currently being built by NASA.
Um,
people have made this calculation whether you could look far enough back in time
that you would essentially look back to that era,
right?
Because the light that comes from this early era just travels for 13 something
billion years to us.
So if you can look that far back,
that will be really awesome.
Now that would be really,
really,
really far away,
which means you've run need really,
really bright sources.
And My,
the first stars veer very bright that individually they're not bright enough to
shine over 13.8 billion light years.
Uh,
however,
maybe if there was a cluster of first doors together that could just be bright
enough.
We don't know.
But it's very speculative when again,
as wasn't theorists so calculated that God bless them.
But we'll have to see how,
how that matches up with the capabilities of a telescope like the Jwst.
Thank you.
The stores that you described seem to have low mass.
Um,
is this typical of what you would predict or do you think it's selection bias
from your search?
It's absolute.
He is selection bias because Stella mass correlates inversely with lifetime.
So the big guys,
they die very soon and the little guys live very long.
So we can only find old status that off very low mass.
And to give you a reference,
the sun and we use the solar mass,
the mass of the sun as a reference,
um,
has a lifetime of 10 billion years.
That's actually easy to remember.
And so the guy who said we are interested in now,
um,
have about 0.6,
2.8 solar masses because they have total lifetimes of 15 to 20 billion years.
So if they are formed 14 billion years ago,
hm.
They're still have a while to go but not that long.
And so they aren't just in the ride evolutionary stage right now for us to find
them and to not have messed up their surfaces from the interior on all sides and
doing all sorts of other wonky things.
Um,
so yeah,
it's kind of by design.
Hi.
So you mentioned that the first generation stars are a very massive like hundred
solar mass and the one you presented is much lighter or 0.6 or eight.
Um,
and consequently there's a huge difference in their lifetime because the first
generation of stars died very fast and this one is 30 and v are years old.
Um,
but they are not very different in terms of the amount of heavier elements in
them because as you said,
there's only a teeny tiny amount in this one and there are zero in the first
generation one.
So it doesn't really seem a striking difference to me.
Why is it that that very teeny tiny amount of heavier elements can make such a
big difference in the mess of forming stars?
Thank you for asking that because I usually don't have time to talk.
Um,
yeah,
so a zero or a little,
it makes a big difference because um,
uh,
heavy elements,
especially carbon and oxygen,
the act as coolants.
So imagine you have this soup and um,
it,
the soup just can't cool.
You add just a sprinkle of salt.
Well,
in this case you change the whole flavor off your soup,
right?
It goes from bland too tasty.
And the same kind of thing happens
when you add a little carbon,
right?
It's suddenly Ken cool.
And it can clump and it can fragment.
And once you have fragmentation,
um,
the cloud breaks up into smaller clumps and then gravity will again do its
thing.
But on smaller length scales,
um,
it's a little bit more complicated than that,
but that's the basic idea.
So as soon as you have some elements,
because you know carbon is a more extended,
a complicated atom,
so it has a lot of transitions for the electrons and there does kind of wiggling
away and carbon oxygen are particularly good and having so called fine structure
lion transition so it can legal,
you know,
whereas a hydrogen atom really it can do nothing.
I mean it has one electron going wrong.
Okay.
I mean the cooling mostly comes from age two.
So you have two electrons because if two protons are HD,
so it's again,
it's a little bit better than that but,
but you see the difference,
right?
So as soon as you have even a few atoms in there,
they radiate away,
which means I send out photons that that can,
that can leave the gas cloud and Poof,
you're energy gone.
So this is some critical medalists city.
So critical amount of elements that you need.
It's very,
very low.
But really,
um,
asha is in this,
this,
this transition.
Okay.
Please correct me if I'm wrong,
but I imagine that what you see in the spectrum is,
is basically determined by the composition of the surface of the star two.
What do we know to what extent that matches the distribution of elements and the
whole star?
Yeah,
that's a great question.
Um,
and that's always a concern.
So that's why we have to make sure that we catch the stars in the ride
evolutionary phase.
Um,
to back up a little bit.
Uh,
people have done for a long time actually that was the beginning of astro
physics with a computer.
They have calculated the evolutionary paths of stars.
So stars evolve,
they get born.
Um,
they started to burn hydrogen to helium later on their burn,
um,
helium to heavier elements.
And so they as a whole sequence that also correlates to how the scar looks from
the outside.
It changes color,
it changes size as a function of what's going on inside.
And so we know very well at what time the,
um,
the star gets mixed and,
and,
and whether the outer layers actually realize what's happening inside.
So our stars,
um,
it's the case that the outer layers don't realize at all what's going on in the
center because they're just burning hydrogen to helium in the center and the
outer layers really don't care at all what's happening there.
They had just sit there under store for billions of years because of their very
slow evolution.
If we were to,
okay,
if we had let's say a 0.9,
so I'm a startup would evolve faster and if we would see it today,
it would still be alive,
but it would have,
um,
it,
it would have already started to burn helium into carbon.
And in the process of that,
the star gets mixed and I'm carbon from the interior gets indeed transporter to
the outer layers so that we call that self in Richmond.
And that's also very interesting to study about Marcella archeology.
Uh,
that's a big no,
no,
because then we can't transfer any more.
What would we see today too?
We know what the composition was before.
MMM.
My sister in law was a telescope driver at Kitt peak and awesome.
Would she,
um,
often the scientists weren't actually necessarily there.
And I expect a lot of times as a scientist you don't actually have to ever get
near the telescope for these observations to occur.
How,
how frequently do you go and do you go for practical reasons or just because
it's,
well actually all of the above so it off.
So it's two most telescopes these days have professional operators and the
astronomer doesn't even need to go there anymore.
Certainly all of the big ones except for the Magellan telescopes that I'm using.
They have the old school policy that if you want to take data you got a better
do it yourself.
And um,
for our discovery work that is actually very beneficial because I need to
inspect the data out right there and right then because you know,
the stars are not observable all night long because they are standing steadily
above my telescope.
They are moving and if I want to keep catching the star because it turned out to
be really interesting.
So we take a quick exposure first,
then we inspected because we all,
we only deal with Candida.
That's fine.
And so we then have to make the decision,
Yay or nay.
So that has to happen fast.
If someone wants to take the data and then we would get it,
you know,
the next day and then we'll look at it.
It might not be observable anymore.
The weather,
my turn bad,
you know,
that kind of moment just kind of goes.
And so for us it's,
it's very good to be at the telescope and focus on how to present on that and
get our data.
Um,
now I traveled to Chile about two or three times a year.
It takes a long time to get there.
Something like 70 hours.
Um,
and I always feel like I need a vacation coming back because you work all night
long,
you have to swap,
switch 12 hours,
right.
Working from days and nights in between.
You have a night over flights down there.
Um,
so that's no fun.
But being there as a lot of fun and then having the data,
it's a lot of fun and,
but I do really think that it's important for at least every student to go to a
telescope wants to see the process.
But with all these big new sky surveys,
people just don't know the data from the Internet.
Now.
And I have come across students who a don't seeing the data is real because it
was downloaded from the Internet.
It was like feet.
Yeah,
sure.
We can make fake data we have that has certain purposes.
Um,
but this the,
the basis,
I mean this as a scientist you,
your work is based on data collection.
Yeah.
And that has been erased from astronomy,
downloading data from the Internet.
It's not data collection,
at least not to me.
So that's another reason why I really enjoy going there because it brings me
back to the root of my profession.
And one of the reasons why I wanted to become an astronomer on the first phase
and being on the mountain top and seeing the sun down and having the mountains,
they had tinge in purple.
And having the night's sky above me.
I mean that's just priceless on top of that.
All right,
so I noticed you use heavier elements.
You won't say metals.
Yes.
Because you're talking to the public and yeah.
Astronomers have hydrogen,
helium and then metals,
everything else.
Right.
I took that slide out.
I haven't caught a few slides.
You want me to elaborate or do you go into it in the book?
Yes.
Okay.
Because I do believe that with sufficient explanation and motivation,
um,
the public can understand a lot of details.
You just got to walk them through.
So what we're talking about is that,
um,
astronomy sound not chemist,
so we can do pretty much whatever we want.
And the universe is a complex and complicated place.
So a long time ago someone came up with a grandiose idea of,
um,
uh,
lumping all the chemical elements into one thing.
And so they called hydrogen because the universe is full of hydrogen x.
Then he'd him as the second most common element.
They call it a why and then all the rest,
that was kind of negligible.
That's z.
So if your dinner conversation ever go stale,
you know,
just tell them what's the universe made of Xyz Hall.
Um,
so,
um,
we look for the stars with the least amount of heavy elements in them,
which means we look for Sas at our port in metals,
all of the elements.
So we call them metal pastas.
So that's the jargon.
But I do use the,
um,
unless I give a long talk.
So in my hour long talks I do,
and putting the shorter ones,
I usually cut it out.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.